Brazilian president Lula da Silva is
leading an offensive to make wealthier
countries responsible for the fate of
the world's rainforests
not Brazil that needs money it's not
Colombia that needs money it's not
Venezuela it's nature that Industrial
Development over 200 years has polluted
that needs compensation for what was
damaged it is nature that needs money
and financing
we eight Amazonian countries were joined
by leaders of the second and the third
largest rainforests which like the
Amazon are at risk from continuous
deforestation
the two presidents of the Republic of
the Congo and the Democratic Republic of
the Congo had traveled to the Brazilian
Amazon to say that their rainforest
known as the lungs of Africa also needs
help to Halt deforestation and
transition to a sustainable economy
the same causes produce the same effects
we have to unite to overcome our common
challenges to guarantee the survival of
humanity
speaking on their behalf Lula criticized
richer Nations for not making good on
commitments to provide a hundred billion
dollars a year in climate financing to
developing nations
we will no longer accept creating a
thesis that is not implemented we are
going to cop28 to tell the rich world
that if they want to preserve the
forests effectively it is necessary to
put money not only to take care of the
forest but to take care of the people
who live in it
earlier leaders of the eight Amazonian
countries had failed to agree on a
Target date for zero deforestation
scientists environmentalists and
Indigenous groups criticized them for
falling short of expectations but Lula
and the others are now putting the onus
on countries that have already destroyed
their own rainforests to put their money
where their mouth is as the climate
crisis worsens they say that they will
join forces to pressure the wealthy
countries to help Finance sustainable
Alternatives Lucia Newman Al Jazeera
Belen Brazil
foreign